les années passent et toujours pas de
marché à magny les hameaux néanmoins
depuis un mois les habitants peuvent
profiter de la rôtisserie la fromagerie
et des spécialités antillaises qui
prennent place chaque mercredi sur la
place de l'hôtel de ville et le
confinement il y est pour quelque chose
pendant confinement il se trouve que sur
les réseaux sociaux on aperçoit une
fromagerie qui avec la fermeture des
marchés fait de la vente et de la
livraison sur la commune de magny les
hameaux jeu discutent directement avec
elle
et je lui explique tout simplement que
on cherche à proposer à des commerçants
à des commerçants autonome de pouvoir
s'installer à magny les hameaux pour
pouvoir créer un un premier lieu de
vente ambulante
les responsables de la fromagerie
accepte et c'est parti info de trek de
spécialités antillaises rejoint le
projet ainsi qu'une rôtisserie la prom'
hager juste à côté de nous on fait des
marchés ensemble vendredi à vélizy donc
elle nous a proposé
on a dit allez on va essayer puis
vadencourt mais je vous dis on aime bien
le cadre des gens sont sympas ils
viennent nous voir ce sans difficulté il
parle avec nous et on a dit allez on
continue mais vente fonctionne bien
cette offre qui s'ajoutent à celles des
supermarchés et commerces du centre
ville séduit largement les habitants
lorsqu'on a eu sur facebook la
publication de la ville comme quoi
calais foutraque maintenant le mercredi
donc voilà on n' y voir la première fois
et maintenant on vient tous les
mercredis
la commune espère voir arriver d'autres
food truck elle invite toutes personnes
intéressées à se manifester